we're in Denver still still and the
great shows great people but we go eat
at uh out of all the places some pizza
place any where's your card was on the
table my card yeah right yeah and our
waitress picks up the card and she's
like wow cool cars cuz on the card my
face is going like this
oh we got it right here yeah right so
this cards on the table and she's
looking at and she's like so what'd he
do for a living so then I go he's a
professional Yeller and I make a lot of
money doing it
yeah I said that you made like like a
few thousand dollars yeah for 15 minutes
of yelling - yelling yeah and she's
buying this whole story and she buys the
whole thing we have the video so we're
gonna show it to you right now right
this is us in Denver at a restaurant
with our [ __ ] waitress and the tilde
and me the professional Yeller perfect
right it's a great expression thank you
using Yeller
that's what he does professional yelling
whatever and enormous and kippur
assemble like how quick so loud about it
you know you'll get people half the
magic that we'll need how much louder
that's pretty loud no invention ham I
thought I could do that 2500 he got paid
today at the game
people me
ah that imagine had something much lower
we can feel the peak on it yeah yeah so
now you see why I appreciate you know it
doesn't have to do with your voice and
that's to do more with like yeah how did
you know that you were a Yeller
how did you know you were professional
yeah I knew ever since I was looking
that you wanted to be a killer you're
stupid no I know ever since I was a
little kid that I had like a loud thing
that whenever I was in school did you
know they're like yeah see that was loud
but it wasn't like a full resonant thing
like if I were to go oh yeah yeah
there's more in the throat yeah where is
he
it comes from the diaphragm watch watch
watch oh and that's just like oh that's
one what one-fiftieth when I can
one-fiftieth know that's like 160 let me
say this one 5000 it's like once 50th is
that crazy then you get on a microphone
I don't you don't want to hear him on a
microphone I'm gonna crack oh dude if
he's had people actually trying to
remember
yeah at the Celtics game yeah no Lakers
yeah I go on the thing I go like today I
go like let's go Lakers but I did
realize I did
50 times this loud let's go Lakers that
crazy I gonna like split check here I
went like I went like 25 times this loud
let's go Lakers
yeah and you know how when people scream
it gets like a screaming voice like like
loud like that
I don't do a screaming voice it's always
resident like you feel like vibrations
why do you feel it yeah and a lot of
people say they feel it in their like
hair or head right let's go Lakers was
like wow now you know I love this
professional Yeller
to the car that's him yelling no
let's go Lakers before Harper's see
there was a lot of problems with that
you'd get like a lot of you'd heard your
voice all right do you know one time I
tried to I heard a yell yeah and we had
to go to the thing I was like Mighty
Ducks game and I was saying let's go
Mighty Ducks and he tried to do it like
that
anybody yeah right now it's just her
right let's go you have to do it from
Lee
let's go mighty dog you have to go like
let's go mighty dog their latest with
Mets
oh yeah that's it's quicker what nuts
Matz Matz the recipe how do we save your
diaper go Mets
thank you yeah whoa okay well if you
meant white plane a happy life no one
was in
Dodgers go Dodgers dozen there you go
but the second syllable wasn't a trail
off what we call a trail off you there's
sound logical terms yeah Dodgers but you
really want to go dodge ours but what
you want to I want to think in your head
yeah
higher on the second civil because your
natural instinct is to go lower the jars
da door somebody don't practice too much
yeah pretty sure you'll be able to do
stuff like this but pretty sitting
around is you stuff like this I once was
a lad who served a term as office butch
when attorneys for Mike didn't know what
is that I swapped out fuzz and I put
aside added up the big front door I
gather look look I promise you she would
have a Booma sign up right in the front
window
advertisement read interpret window and
all of a sudden success coming out of
the blue I guarantee if you did that
you'd probably hurt your voice right I
started pulling things I found out that
we dull and then all of a sudden sectors
god man this is like 125th I put a sign
up right in the front window
advertisement right in the front window
and all of a sudden said sex coming out
of the blue that's 125th and how about I
can do oh wow
alright let's order it okay